los oficiales responsables del fatal
tiroteo de richard brooks no serán
acusados según un fiscal especial de
georgia el disparo que le quitó la vida
al hombre negro de 27 años en junio de
2020 fue justificado por que brooks se
armó con uno de los pacers de los
oficiales un acto que según la fiscalía
es una amenaza de violencia física
dadas las circunstancias rápidamente
cambiantes era objetivamente razonable
que se usara la fuerza letal concluimos
que si era necesario
esto no es un george floyd que estaba en
el suelo con un oficial arrodillado
sobre su cuello este no es el caso en
este caso estos hechos son distintos
el hecho empezó cuando la policía llegó
a inspeccionar a brooks porque habían
reportado que un hombre dormía en un
vehículo estacionado en el carril de
acceso de un restaurante luego de
recibir una prueba de alcoholemia los
oficiales intentaron esposarle brooks se
resistió tomó el tester de uno de los
oficiales e intentó huir uno de los
agentes disparó
brooks fue llevado al hospital
y ahí murió el suceso que ocurrió a dos
semanas del asesinato de george floyd en
2020 en minneápolis exacerbó la
indignación de los ciudadanos por el
excesivo y constante uso de la fuerza
por parte de la policía contra las
personas negras en eeuu poco después de
la muerte de brooks el fiscal del
distrito de ese momento acusó a los
uniformados de homicidio grave asalto
agravado y violación de juramento pero
el fiscal no fue reelegido y su sucesor
fue recusado del caso
garde fault quien disparó contra brooks
fue despedido por la entonces alcaldesa
de atlanta que solange barnes pero un
año después fue reincorporado por la
junta de servicio civil de atlanta
asegurando que fue despedido
indebidamente